it may have taken more than half a year
but tsm
have once again established themselves
among north america's best teams in the
valorant champions tour
after months of disappointment last
weekend
they made an impressive run through
challengers qualifiers and now find
themselves in playoffs with the region's
elite teams
as they vie for the opportunity to
represent north america
at masters 3 in berlin so how did this
team go from being a dead meme to
actually being relevant again in north
america
and can they now go all the way let's
find out
[Music]
okay then friends with playoffs coming
up and champions at the end of the year
there literally is not a better time in
this life
to subscribe to the score esports to
make sure that you're up to date
with all the news that's coming your way
and that you'll never miss a video
just like this one do it tsm is looking
strong
why is this a big deal well in a
nutshell they haven't been doing well
for a long time and that's a big deal
because way back
when this crazy valerant ride began tsm
was one of the best teams in north
america
so let's start the story there in the
early days of valorum tsm came
flying out of the gates as one of the
best teams in the scene
along with the likes of sentinels who
have done pretty well since then
let's just say that they played around
wardell's operator perfectly which was
500 credits cheaper back then
and also a hell of a lot easier to use
by august 2020
tsm were looking pretty unstoppable
winning
three tournaments back to back to back
including a finals win over
sentinels in the faze clan invitational
now it's gonna be a 1v1
it's just up to sick he has been
spectacular but it's not gonna matter
because wardell gets the final shot and
t s m are your phase
valorent invitational champions the
team's confidence was at an
all-time high with star orbit wardell
announcing tsm
were the best team in the world bordeaux
might have talked big
but the man could definitely back it up
not only was he an incredible author
he was also considered one of the best
jets in north america at the time
after winning the pittsburgh knights
invitational in which they took down
sentinels in the finals
once again you'd honestly be crazy to
bet against them
player one last person remaining hasn't
gotten the spike down but finally he's
going to get it he has wasted so much
time on site
color right through this right through
the wall going to get it
ladies and gentlemen your knights
gauntlet 10k
champions but what you just saw was the
last time tsm would win anything
for a long time in december they played
in riot's first
major tournament in first strike north
america
this was just a few months after they
had hard nerfed the op
increasing its cost of 5 000 credits
reducing its scope
and movement speed and reducing its fire
rate now if you didn't pay attention
early on in pro
valorum this change made waves the game
was notably extremely defender sided at
high levels and the art being so cheap
was a huge part of that tsm were part of
a huge group of teams that would
frequently buy
two and sometimes even wheeled three ops
on ct's side
anyway despite looking fairly strong in
first strike
tsm fell at the final hurdle losing 3-1
to 100 thieves
in the final in the new year things went
from bad to worse
tsm floundered in vct challenger events
picking up top four finishers in
qualifiers before bowing out well before
an
actual final this all led to something
that would have been
unthinkable just six months before tsm
failing to qualify for vct stage one
masters
now if you don't know masters is a big
deal the top teams from regions around
the world battle
it out for the chance to earn circuit
points after three masters the teams
with the most circuit points qualify
for valorant champions that's the manger
to end
all majors featuring the best teams in
the world
to crown the best valorant team on the
planet
so when tsm failed to qualify for stage
one masters
alarm bells began to ring they look like
a shadow of their former selves
with some people not even ranking them
in the top 20 teams in north america
although they'd individually had pop-off
moments and their star power
was still undeniable something just
wasn't clicking
but they're just not quite i don't know
they're not they're not quite all there
as a
as a team the like the the setup and the
teamwork and the
ability to deal with gen g playing a
slightly faster tempo
wasn't there this this day by may tsm
had failed to qualify for stage 2
masters and chose to bench cutler from
their starting roster
and part ways with their head coach
tailored going into stage three
tsm were one of the favorites to take
the whole thing but managed to get their
worst competitive result to date
after losing to noble in the round of 16
open qualifier the frustration among the
players was at an
all-time high but for others tsm were
bordering on a meme at this point
noble beat tsm yeah but it's tsm
sorry that's toxic i'm so sorry how dare
i say that about
rank 14 high warlord haze change was
needed
tsm basically had one last shot to make
it to their first masters or they could
kiss champions goodbye altogether
and as they say if you can't beat them
just take their players
as tsm picked up leviathan from noble by
this point it also acquired bang
the young fragger who'd shown promising
flashes for them during that tournament
now with this new roster tsm hoped they
had a chance to right the sinking ship
they fought their way through close
series with gen g and t1
and you could tell that something was
just different this time
after the t1 win tsm had now locked in a
spot
in playoffs which really seemed like a
weight off their shoulders
what's it feel like to kind of like
release this team to knock them out and
now all of a sudden play with his team
to get them in
it feels really relaxing and really
rewarding in the upper final showdown
with luminosity
bang and leviathan really came into
their own to help deliver a
2-0 victory this was the best that tsm
had looked
in a long time in the grand final they
faced off against faze clan who had
clawed their way through the entire
lower bracket
and tsm smelled blood their first game
on ascent was incredibly close with tsm
managing to throw an 11-6
lead but tsm strolled through the next
two maps winning both
13-6 going into map four they may have
started out the series a bit shaky
but they were going to finish it strong
tsm are unrelenting oh cory though opens
things up but
it's an even better response from
leviathan we get the guardian coming out
from bang
it's dead on the garage entrance it's so
ready for that
and it says it's even more ready for a
13-2 tsm
are going to win the grand finals here
excellent work from them in fact
i don't think there was a single point
where it was really in question
so now we find ourselves in a situation
that once looked so
familiar tsm looked good they're
clicking but playoffs will be their real
test
tsm joined seven of north america's
strongest teams for the chance to earn
one
of three spots to represent north
america at masters berlin
given the short history of valor and
esports next weekend's event has the
potential to be the most competitive
event
we've seen in north america many of the
teams look primed to just make a run
for the likes of sentinels this is just
another chance to assert their dominance
having already qualified for champions
through circuit points
but while they sit on 540 points after
winning masters 1 and 2
tsm are on a measly 40 points aside from
the last chance qualifier
this is do or die for them their first
game is against team
envy and if they win that they'll play
the winner of sentinels versus ryze
but should tsm even be scared they
showed no fear in the challenger's two
qualifiers and were clearly the best
team
in the bracket but can they now go all
the way in playoffs
some people think they might i
think that csm actually have a pretty
good shot i think they're peaking at the
right time i think everything's clicking
they're peaking at the right time
and yeah i think that they have an uh
they have a real shot i feel like
in this tournament specifically even
more so than the last
everyone was kind of on point everybody
was having moments yeah
i think haze has still been mega
consistent for them the whole point of
playoffs is to pit the very best teams
against each other
and this iteration of tsm hasn't had the
chance to do that yet but their scouting
of leviathan and bang
has done wonders for the team it's
brought confidence to wardell
sabrosa and hayes whose talent has
always been there
but now they have the confidence to
really show up tsm doesn't want
challengers too
i think they're looking way better than
the last iteration of the
um they definitely made some good moves
and i think a big big part of this game
is confidence
and like after going off and went on
challenger 2 like you're going to go
into playoffs
a lot of confidence well like the
challenges one teams have kind of been
sitting around and like
going for a bit with their early success
in valoran centered around
wardell's opping and their strong
defender side
this new lineup has allowed them to
diversify their skill sets a little
in particular subrosa has looked really
good at supporting his team and
playmaking on sky
bang is an aggressive fragger that the
team has always needed and leviathan has
stood out on two of the game's most
difficult agents in silver and viper
so do they have what it takes to
represent north america in berlin
well that's what playoffs are for
they played around wardell's operator
i'm just trying to sound like i'm an
absolute pro at it i'm like
you guys know right
[Music]
done it again who remembers that good
times lads good times